tonight hi my name is Annie is fara
there and tonight I'm gonna tell you
this story the true story behind a
league of their own
cheers Cheers
we started a story but Marge and Helen
Kelly and two sisters growing up in
Vancouver Canada these two women are
natural athletes they're so thick and
tight and they're like a Yowie joined a
fast pitch softball league together okay
so now we're gonna fast forward a little
bit to 1942 we're in the midst of World
War two and the draft is going on full
force now this guy the Commissioner of
the MLB Kenesaw Mountain Landis he's
ain't a name he's like I'm the new
morover Commissioner of Major League and
minor league baseball and while I'm
calling the shots everyone's being
drafted into World War two so music okay
I my big-boy pants on
I'm I figure this out because Phillip K
Wrigley silky Wrigley is like Chomp
Chomp
hello and Kenesaw Mountain Landis is
like all my men 3,000 minor league
players major league players are gone to
war okay really he's like okay I've got
an idea for you we are gonna capitalize
on the popularity of women
badass women and it's like the 40s right
that's that's a crazy time to do this so
Philip K Wrigley and his buddy Ken cells
go out scouting all throughout the
Midwest
lo and behold who do they run into but
Helen and Marge Callahan what are they
doing there they are playing fast pitch
softball in Helen and Mart are like we
are dominating this field
Philip and can run out to this they run
out to the field and they're like you
the both of you we need you both you got
to be on our team and they sign on the
door wide $75 a week so they're both on
the Minneapolis Marion hence Millerites
so Marge and Helen are like we're on
this team this is in tight they're
playing double headers like a hundred
and fifteen degree weather in Philip K
Wrigley is like I know how to sell a
product and I need these women to look
like women these chaperones are like I
am going to make sure that their hair is
curl their lipstick is on there's makeup
is fully done their skirts or ironed
before they head out onto the field
people are full to watch these women in
these adorable dresses play in baseball
like men and Marge Callahan Helen
Callahan are knocking this out of
park women are stealing bases they're
like what's that mother no Phillip K
Wrigley looks like this
these aren't women playing baseball
these are baseball players yeah dude
it's so badass right this is my seventh
inning stretch this is mine
all right let's play ball yeah okay
so 1945 comes right and World War two is
ending
Georgia Maggio Ted Williams the major
minor league players come back and
they're like hi everybody
yeah we've been a war is terrible we're
ready to hit some balls so they they and
it ends up fizzling out thirty years
passes and this story is forgotten until
1985 there was a reunion Helen Callan
delays this harder now than it was
earlier but you still doing it
Kelly can delay Helen's oldest son was
like I'm gonna record this
he web sighs Kim Carter and all these
old ladies are playing ball like they
did back in the forties
Kelly can delay creates a league of
their own documentary it's a huge Indio
and Penny Marshall sees this documentary
she's like what the I didn't know this
existed history Oh be me I should
make a movie about this story because
it's important for women of all ages and
if it wasn't for a league of our own
nobody would have ever known that women
can throw a ball like in the man
what
you